steve bannon's been found guilty of two
charges in contempt of congress trial
it's a minimum of two years for each
count but would they really give him
that long some are saying it's going to
be two months he's going to get the bare
minimum they're going to say two two two
uh two months to run concurrently for
both counts but we'll see the story
steve bannon said we may have lost a
battle here today but we are not going
to lose this war
bannon is the former executive chairman
of breitbart news as well as a former
advisor to president trump the
conviction comes after a four-day trial
during which the justice department
argued bannon believes he's above the
law and showed he chose to show his
contempt for congress
congress's authority and its process by
refusing to comply with the january 6
committee's subpoenas
well instead of just reading this let me
just ask hannah claire what's going on
with the story are there any other
developments or you know what's your
reporting on it yeah well the major
thing is that he has been following this
line that he
was exercising executive privilege from
president trump that trump's lawyers had
encouraged him not to
testify before the committee not to
submit any documents and they're saying
this is within you know official
protocol it's acceptable the january 6
committee says no this he knew he was
supposed to comply with the subpoenas he
has to turn over the documents he needed
to testify you have to remember that the
january 6 committee has subpoenaed 100
people the only for other person to be
indicted is uh
peter peter navarro thank you um and
throughout the trial was a four-day
trial and we had
basically the justice department saying
this is ridiculous it's simple he was
supposed to be there and we had uh
bannon's attorneys arguing that no
there's precedent in the way and also he
was in the middle of negotiating terms
we've seen a couple other people i think
mo brooks said yeah i'll testify before
january 6 but i want it to be televised
i want it to be recorded there are
people who are
uncomfortable with the way this
investigation is being carried out so a
lot of the story or a lot of the feeling
is that they're trying to make an
example of bannon right here the first
one that comes to mind is uh constantine
is this becoming soviet-esque
yeah i don't know too much about i i
think it's scary in a different way to
me as a complete outsider who maybe
doesn't follow the legal details but
just seeing how divided this country is
uh and i love america i think it's a
brilliant place but seeing how angry and
people both sides are trying to destroy
each other right down burn everything
down to the ground is very worrying
because it's not just about america like
we everywhere in the world in the uk
where i live we import all of this stuff
and then we start doing the same thing
to each other so it's really really
worrying the way things are going man
i think um
when you have the previous
administration
and the rival political party
arresting the
when you have the current administration
sorry and rival democratic party
arresting their rivals and the previous
administration yeah we're there man so
steve bannon is
let me put this away the january 6
committee is a sham it's it's it's fake
it's lies they included me in their
evidence
so so right away i'm already like
everybody i know most people listening
know this but um were you the shaymin
guy no no they they claimed that uh
trump supporters were encouraging people
to go down and get violent
and they put me in their montage of
people because
i commented on a comment trump made as i
was reading a news article i said donald
trump says this will happen and it's
called for his supporters so they put me
in this montage because their goal is
just to lie and drive escalation
what we've been seeing the democrats do
is they've been putting money into
trump-supported candidates like trump
endorsed candidates
so that they win because they believe
come november they will then beat the
trump candidate right
they're coming out on january 6th and
saying it's an existential threat to our
country but then funding the message and
propping it up
so steve bannon gets a subpoena and
first and foremost he didn't just say
screw you
he said
the president has executive privilege
meaning you know we don't have to comply
with congress
there should have been
there's got to be some negotiation right
like if the pr if they're they're
arguing that trump's not the president
therefore doesn't count but i'm like but
he was like you lose your executive
privilege the monk out of office then
we'd be going after every single
president ever why aren't they going
after bush over over the middle eastern
war stuff
this is purely
i think we're getting into uh
authoritarian
fascistic communistic whatever you want
to call it
where
there's the uniparty neocons and neolibs
and if you oppose them they will destroy
you and the the the the people who work
in government are just gonna you know
turn along with it well let's remember
that the two republicans on this
committee are adam kinzinger and liz
chaney who are notoriously unpopular in
the republican party i mean they'll say
it's bipartisan but you have to question
why they didn't oppose
appoint someone who had a more uh
opposing perspective from the democrats
that are leaving this committee it's
clearly not something that they were
interested in doing i think with
bannon
ultimately
he has just become
a man with a target on his back they
know that if they can make this adviser
to trump who
is outside he he represents to a lot of
normal americans a lot of normal liberal
americans sort of the fear of who trump
is cultivating or who trump works with
and i think by
fine i mean i think if he goes to jail
for let's say 60 days they also can find
him between 100 and 100 thousand dollars
so if they hit him with the 200 000 fine
they put him in jail for 60 days they
have sort of landed an arrow on on
bannon and that's really all this is tim
can i steal man like i'm just curious
because i always like playing devil's
advocate is what i do on our show so if
you just take the steel man version of
the democrat argument right that what
wouldn't they say what happened was on
january 6 with an attempt to overthrow
democracy and we have to make sure this
never happens again which is why we're
doing this is that what they would say
so one more time the democrats are
arguing that the january 6th it's an
attempt to overthrow democracy and they
have to follow the legal process to make
sure that never happens again that's
essentially that that's what there are
and what's wrong with that argument it's
not real
so they're trying to so i'll give you an
example using me
they're trying to argue there was an
organized effort a conspiracy to do to
you know overthrow the us government
even though the fbi says that's not true
initially they did now you've got
seditious conspiracy charges and it's
and it's it's just i think it's it's
it's all fake for a variety of reasons
one you've got
they had this unnamed co-conspirator and
the guy actually ex like revealed
himself saying like here's the chat
messages we were saying no violence it
was like it was like
criticizing people who are arguing for
violence you've got ray epps for
instance this guy who's out in the
street on camera telling people to go in
no charges the media defends them the
reality is
there were no cops
uh protecting the perimeter like there
was no substantial police force there
were some cops police opened the door to
the capitol did you know that yeah
police opened the door they fanned
people in there was a riot at one side
and there were people shoving their way
in some areas and maybe half of the
people who walked in were invited in by
the police the cops opened the doors
waved them in oh no all of this i agree
with and i totally accept i guess what
i'm saying is i think from the from
their perspective a more plausible
explanation is they thought donald trump
was a hitler
right yeah and then his supporters
stormed the capital
storm inverted commerce well i mean if
if their perspective is based on the
fact that they're wrong oh no i don't
think they can believe unicorns
i'm not disagreeing with you i'm just
saying i think the reason that they're
behaving in this way is they decided
evil hitler and his supporters did this
no they're they're funding they're
funding these people you think it's
deliberate i mean it's i don't think
it's reported ver fact that the
democrats governor association put 1.16
million dollars into who's dan cox uh
yeah dan cox of maryland he's running as
the republican candidate for governor
they're literally funding the people
they claim are threatening democracy so
there's no way they believe that's true
it's not monolithic though the democrats
it gets kind of vague because when
marjorie taylor green was here last
night i listened to you guys talking she
was saying the democrats want to she's
talking about the democrat congressmen
and women but when you say the democrats
you're talking about like the governor's
association yeah the democratic national
committee and and the voters are a bunch
and sometimes the voters themselves
ignorant people who are marching in
lockstep with fake news because the
people that
assign themselves democrat when they
vote are considered democrats but
they're not the democratic congress
people so it's it's a lot of discipline
we're talking about the political party
it's just such a large disproportionate
people it is like some want this some
want that some think it was no no no
you're
this is not not the point the point is
there's democratic leadership and
infrastructure and the infrastructure
and power and leadership and money is
has an agenda and a goal true but to say
that because the democratic governors
association is funding uh trump
candidates doesn't mean that all
democrats are funding trump candidates
no it means the democratic establishment
is applying resources in that direction
in many ways while simultaneously the
same establishment is screaming that
this is the end of demand so who
controls the democratic establishment i
mean you can point to a handful of
people for a while it was hillary
clinton i don't uh uh you can say barack
obama was the leader of the party
there's a bunch of people involved
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you